Your recommendation from the killer growth was minimum of 15 capsules, capsules of digestimes
plus in the morning and the same in the evening 30 minutes away from food.
So understand that protocol.
That is Dr. William Kelly's protocol for enzyme therapy.
So enzyme therapy or cancer is to be taking high dose of pancreatic enzymes that you would
take on an empty stomach.
So high doses of pancreatic enzymes on an empty stomach so that you absorb them and the
idea is that the enzymes can help break down the cancer and the slime layer around the cancer
so that your immune system could be better get at it and attack it.
Now Dr. Kelly's protocol is really best for cancers of the intestinal tract, cancers
of the pancreas, cancers of the liver, and maybe bile duct cancer.
That's where really shines is those types of cancers.
Certainly it's a therapy that should be attempted by anybody if the other therapies are not working.
The reason why I say, well, why don't you just jump into that right away?
You can't.
The negative of it is that you're taking so darn many pills, we're using 15 to 30 digestimes
in the morning and in the evening and you have to take it about 30 minutes away from
food and you can see in this person's questions, I did not get up to about 2 p.m.
I'm going to bed at 9.30, I have a smoothie around 10 a.m. in bed, I took 15 enzymes around
9 a.m. and threw up a half hour later.
That's not uncommon, that's a problem.
So stomach was queasy for five to six hours and it abstained in bed even longer.
The next time I took four of them, about 7 p.m., my stomach hurt for four hours.
The next time I tried to take two and I could still feel it in my stomach but it was tolerable.
Help.
You have to work up on it.
This is an issue.
So Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez, who was one of my teachers taught me about Dr. Kelly's protocols.
He was very big into Dr. Kelly's protocols and he actually wrote several books on Dr.
William Kelly.
I had long discussions with him about Dr. William Kelly, I highly admire him but a lot of
people can't do it.
You realize that the pills, the pancreatic enzymes that they had at the time and that Dr.
Gonzales was using 15 years ago were at a dosage that he had to have people take 75 pills
in the morning and 75 pills at night before they went up and I don't know how anybody could
swallow 150 of the pills a day plus they were taking other supplements.
I just don't know how people could do it.
Well the truth was a lot of people, there's just a way they could do it.
It was a pretty minimal amount of people that they could do that.
Now with the advent of the fermented digestimes plus which is so much higher dose per capsule,
we could get by with taking a lot less of them.
The problem still exists as in this person's questions, an example of this person's questions.
One thing that you could do is you could open them up and put them in the smoothie.
It could be actually the capsule itself that is causing stomach upset.
It's very possible that it's the capsule itself.
So I would try two things, if you're like there's no way I can open up these capsules, then
I would start really small and start with two in the morning, two at night.
If you can open up the capsules, I would start opening up and maybe start with maybe three
or four in your smoothie in the morning and three or four in some type of smoothie drink
in the evening.
Well, you're supposed to take them away from food.
Can I take them with my smoothie?
Yes, take them with your smoothie.
You'll get some of the enzymes wasted digesting the smoothie, but you're not getting it.
You're not eating a whole meal and having them wasted that way.
That's the way I would do it if I were you.